Team Oval Browns motto is that there's
no such thing as impossible it's his job
to transport things that are
particularly big and heavy like this
digger it has to be taken from here to a
building site in the Western German city
of Essen the excavator weighs almost 50
tons together with the weight of the
transport vehicle itself that makes 80
tons a load that's almost twice as heavy
as is permitted on many German roads the
authorities tell us which roads and
bridges we can use you're allowed to
travel on the motorways at certain times
the route from here to the next
construction site is laid down very
precise lated vehicles transporting
heavy loads are only allowed to travel
at certain times they're not allowed to
move between 6:30 and 8:00 a.m. or from
3:30 p.m. onwards that makes journey
planning difficult
t-mobile brand comes from Dortmund and
knows the roads here inside and out at
the moment there are no traffic jams
inside but the traffic news on the radio
sounds a little ominous there are a lot
of building sites in the world and lots
of motorways and commuters if there's
some hitch in the prescribed route you
can't simply take another road
congestion is particularly common here
in this sprawling conurbation on some
days the roads are gridlocked and the
volume of traffic is on the rise it's a
bit busy here we'll have to see
I'm not sure if I'll make it all the way
in times tell me if it continues the
vehicle is just one of 25 vehicles in
the bluhdorn haulage company's fleet
that's on the road in the rural region
today it's not easy to battle through
the heavy traffic day in and day out to
track the movements of each truck and
check that what you've planned is going
to work out things don't work out time
is money and we're confronted with
problems every day client who hasn't
finished construction on time but who's
already contracted out his equipment
elsewhere while someone else is waiting
for excavation to be finished so they
can get started one thing leads to the
next after spending three hours on the
road Ville brunt arrives in essence
slightly behind schedule
the next day he's given a new assignment
taking this huge 50 ton concrete pipe to
Dortmund the truck is not permitted to
cross most of the bridges in the area
with a load like this the driver has to
make a detour to the can't drive from
the a46 directly onto the a3 because the
a three overpass needs work we'll take
the next exit and Hilden the state of
the motorway overpasses and bridges in
north rhine-westphalia are a real
headache for the haulage firm many need
to be patched up or rebuilt from scratch
this bridge over the rhine is one of the
last that's open to vehicles carrying
heavy loads we can cross only a few of
the Rhine bridges with heavy loads many
are not open to loads over 40 tonnes
manufacturing companies in the Ruhr
region also need their goods transported
longer journey times mean higher costs
for them too
hauliers can usually gauge the state of
the local economy well at the start of
the year they didn't have many orders on
their books long as long as the
manufacturing sector keeps exporting
things or producing things for the
domestic market and will have stuff to
transport when no one here makes
anything anymore then we'll be out of a
job under 50 all the drivers are used to
the everyday chaos on the roads of the
Ruhr region but it poses a substantial
risk to the economic regeneration of the
area